i know you had um
gone on the road with your brother
before and obviously uh him being a part
of
one of the biggest operations in hip-hop
tde like what what are some things that
you saw
as a spectator
kind of behind the curtain of what tde
does that you've learned and kind of
applied to d smoke absolutely um
tde employees don't give nobody no
passes
like if it's not right they own it and
i'm talking about these are nice people
you know what i'm saying tde got some
gangsters and then they got some
scholars they got you know people see
top you know what i'm saying
but they got employees from different
backgrounds but
the culture of it is if it's not right
we're not accepting it you know and
so you know coming from like the regular
workplace whether it be a school where
you're a teacher it's like i want to be
the agreeable person so it's like no
we'll be flexible i understand there's
none of that there's none of that
because when you show up
if you make it a a habit or if you have
a tendency to give people passes like
whether it be the hotel stuff ain't
right or you're just not treating us
right
you don't make a habit of giving people
money that ain't doing you right and but
when they treat you right and they take
good care of you then you have a contact
for a long period of time and you go
back to that business and you they take
care of the people that take care of
them if you're giving them if you
disrespect them because you think we
just some rappers showing up
like not that they're gonna go big but
they might go big in a very professional
way like okay we're not having the right
conversation with the right person let's
talk to somebody else are you that
person okay well since you're the top
person i want you to talk to my guy you
know what i'm saying who's the legal
person right because i'm feeling real
disrespected right you know however it
is and
when that starts happening things start
to get real tight around your
organization and then you show up with a
different level of confidence because
people
p your reputation is that your your
expectation because your expectation of
yourself is high your expectation of how
people deal with you is high and if they
meet that then you are all good you know
what i'm saying there's no problems it's
not like we're looking for problems
we're just looking for perfection you
know what i'm saying so being on tour
with them um it taught me that
it taught me that it's all hands on deck
it taught me that
it taught me business structure right
because
there's top dog but each artist has
their own day-to-day
one or two people then as a company they
have
people who are on multiple teams you got
somebody who might be on tour with
isaiah one
one
group of months and if isaiah's out off
cycle they'll be helping out with the
sur stuff you know what i'm saying
because i saw there was a uh
uh
part where matt you know matt shout out
to man
[Music]
yeah matt came on tour with us um
and because for some reason edgar you
know couldn't do a certain couple dates
and um so then you just see these people
picking up slack so now it's like okay i
want to structure myself like the
winning teams you know what i'm saying
if if i'm in a race i gotta have an
engine that the same winning car had
yeah otherwise you know i'm already i'm
already handicapped so
um it just taught me that ethic it
taught me to be gangster about your [ __ ]
you know and not not
not unnecessarily not that you know
projecting acting tough gangster [ __ ]
it's none of that because it's that calm
like respect treat people with respect
but anytime people
are like careless in how they deal with
you it's addressed you know and
corrected if possible and if they
correct their self then you right back
on right boy like oh cool see i knew we
handled that you know so